the following contains spoilers for
seasons four and five of Game of Thrones
previously on The Game of Thrones honest
trailer babes
from the network whose content you love
thanks to someone else's HBO Go password
comes two more seasons of the show that
used violence at beers to trick non
nerds into liking fantasy game bros time
for honest trailers Game of Thrones how
is the song so good we turn to TV's most
expensive looking Renaissance Faire
where the grounded realism of the first
three seasons has slowly given way to
crazy heavy metal album art
and return to the bandwagon show that
everyone loves now even though it
constantly makes you want to kill
yourself as they keep introducing new
and exciting characters to root for then
finds new and exciting ways to kill them
off it's like The Walking Dead if they
still had any balls the King Justin
Bieber is finally gone now a new
smirking little ship will take his place
as the fictional character you most want
dead and since this works so well when I
said it last time God if he doesn't die
this season I'm gonna kill him myself
he's like invincible Joffrey but it's
not just the a hos that are left alive
all the unforgettable heroes who made it
through the first three seasons are back
plus all those side characters whose
names you're still trying to remember in
my town
Tyrells plus a bunch of new people plus
even the swords have names now they say
the best source of names
earth keeper knows where I like mine's
needle man even the inanimate objects
have names
speaking of which we all remember Jon
Snow right catch up with the man who
still knows nothing you know nothing Jon
Snow watches his wisdom bravery and
honor finally gets rewarded in the
typical Game of Thrones way but he's not
the only fan favorite that the show will
probably mark for death just to spite us
tyrion lannister returns and peter
dinklage takes his acting to new heights
and speeches that want him at Emmy I did
not kill Joffrey but I wish that I and
some speeches they definitely left off
his Emmy reel then there's Daenerys
Targaryen
she's got an army ships a good friend
and some dragons now it's finally time
for her to stay where she is
I will not sail for Westeros seriously
I'm not paid to stop the wheel I'm going
to break the wheel great again can we
just fast-forward to that part
witnesses show there was already full of
disturbing stuff double town on its own
brutality featuring skinning people
alive eating people alive burning
children alive while their parents watch
forced sex between siblings next to the
of their dead son and being sexually
assaulted by the pastor of the man who
killed your family
while the castrated slave who killed
your friends is forced to watch geez
where they go from here you know what
don't answer that
so get ready for another three seasons
of must-see television full of amazing
battles shocking twists and stuff you
just kind of sit through and wait to be
over door pain because sooner or later
you know you're gonna get some babes
Oh shame I don't want to see these boobs
these boobs are too wrapped up and
character development this used to be
fun well at least the boobs can't get
worse than this right I was so wrong oh
my eyes hey bird go to starring go to
starring starring cruelty
animal cruelty
perhaps not
I rolls
Littlefinger's accent i suppose all of
our ancestors came from somewhere else
little fingers other accent you're right
he wasn't involved in Joffrey's path
dogs
stan is brooding in a dark room che
being called a [ __ ] she's the [ __ ] I
told you she was a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
I was his [ __ ] I can't be in love with
a [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't have children with
the [ __ ] I am no [ __ ] and the
Lannister family's drinking problem you
already drank yourself across the Narrow
Sea drink more than you used to yes
there are faster ways to kill yourself
father disowned me today can I drink
myself to death from the road to Meereen
clash of clans TV fans think they know
as much as the book fans cuz they're all
caught up now so adorable tell me about
the Andal invasion dance of dragons and
all five Blackfyre rebellion then we'll
talk dragons was it a dance be sure to
subscribe for more honest trailers hey
screen junkies need a shoulder to cry on
after each brutal episode of Game of
Thrones
then join honest trailers writer Spencer
Gilbert and the rest of how screen
junkies every Monday at 1 p.m. Pacific
who are watching Thrones as we break
down the most recent episode of Game of
Thrones live you can watch our recap of
the first episode of season 6 the red
woman and recaps of all 5 previous
seasons for free right now by clicking
the box or going to screen junkies calm
so check it out now or we'll send the
mountain to find you Betty bought a bit
of butter but the butter was too bitter
so Betty bought some better butter to
make the bitter butter better ha the
fate of the entire world can wait until
tomorrow they'd like to get the
Landmarks good night sweet prince
this is what it sounds like when doves
cry